before entering Downing Street yesterday
a pledge to govern with Integrity
professionalism and accountability how
can you square that with the
reappointment of swella Braverman well
suela made a mistake she has said
herself that she made a mistake she's
apologized for that mistake and she
stood down at the time but ultimately
she has uh I think got very very clear
ideas about how we improve the
performance of the home office both in
terms of border control policing how we
make sure we crack down on crime she's
very passionate about that got a very
clear agenda for that and obviously that
the Prime Minister wanted to see that
delivered this was no minor mistake she
was sacked on the advice of the cabinet
secretary after not just sharing from
her personal email but for pre-releasing
details of a ministerial statement so
I'll ask it again when Richie sunac
talks about displaying Integrity
professionalism and accountability in
government you're not telling me that
she's the best person for the job given
she was sacked from being very good at a
handful of days ago well she has said
that she she made an error she has
apologized for that and the Prime
Minister has clearly taken uh the
apology at uh you know in in the manner
that she wanted to put across she has
shown uh a willingness to take
responsibility for what happened but
ultimately he has decided that he wants
to see the agenda that she has set out
that very important crime fighting
agenda back in the heart of government
she is back in cabinet isn't she because
she provided her endorsement at farishi
sunak ahead of him becoming prime
minister that's the simple truth of this
well if you look at the Parliamentary
numbers if you look at the Parliamentary
numbers it was clear and clear really
very very early on that Rishi was going
to have uh the majority and as it went
on to uh to be clear the overwhelming
majority of the support of the
Parliamentary party Frank I don't think
he needed the endorsement of anyone at
MP that is yeah well it's the way to
look at it because the numbers speak for
themselves
she gets sacked for a significant
security breach she meets with Rishi
sunak she provides her endorsement for
Rishi sunak she finds herself back in
cabinet in six days genuinely
people will be watching this screaming
at the television at the idea that their
intelligence is being insulted by the
fact that she was returned to cabinet on
the basis of her strengths rather than
on the basis of the endorsement I mean
even if it didn't take place that's what
it looks like well look I can't I can't
control I can't control people's
perception of events but I can see what
I saw is that Rishi didn't basically
need any uh endorsements and and
actually look my appointment shows my
appointment showed I you know I
supported someone else now I know Rishi
is an incredibly smart politician who
has incredibly experienced Chancellor
and has got a very clear understanding
of what we need to do to get the British
economy in the place where we want it to
be now but I endorse someone else
nevertheless nevertheless
he asked me to stay in my position uh
the simple truth matter is he didn't
need any particular endorsements because
it was so clear that the Parliamentary
party wanted him at the at the helm
there will be people however then if
even if they take that at face value you
could question the Integrity the
property of a new prime minister who
returns someone to one of the great
offices of State let's not forget you
know a handful of days after she was
sacked from it I mean is there that much
of a lack of talent in conservative
ranks these days that Zoella bravaman is
truly the only person who can do the job
well look that's what it looks like well
you want to be you want to be critical
of us uh uh politicians and of course
that is that is an important part of the
of a function of uh scrutiny but the
simple the simple fact of the matter is
Wella has a very very clear idea and set
out a very clear agenda about getting
control of our borders which is
incredibly important cracking down on
crime which is incredibly important she
made an error she uh uh apologized for
that and it's clear that uh the the
commitment that she's made to crack down
on crime is an important one for all of
us and that's why the Prime Minister
appointed does this mean that Russia
will be appointing an Ethics advisor I
mean presumably not well the I mean the
ultimately an Ethics advisor people keep
using this as if it's some kind of uh um
you know foundation stone of government
it's expected to have something to say
about the reappointment of Sue Ella
bravaman well the uh the point is we
have uh assistant cabinet secretary
there is a whole system in terms of
propriety and ethics uh within uh
government having one additional person
in in what is already a multi-individual
function I'm not convinced is uh is the
is the golden bullet uh that or the
Silver Bullet rather that some people's
Justice
um let's talk about the the biggest
pressing issues facing the country at
the moment cost of living crisis we had
been led to believe that we would be
getting a statement from the chancellor
on Halloween reports this morning that
that it could be delayed what's your
understanding of where we are well I
haven't had a specific confirmation of
dates but obviously just yesterday we
had a new prime minister he's going
through the appointment of his
government he of course wants to take
some time to work on the detail of that
he's been Chancellor he will of course
have a very a good understanding of the
figures he'll be working closely with
Jeremy in terms of the production of
that so it's like you're suggesting it
might look but we know it needs to come
soon we know people want certainty we
know people want a clear idea of the
government's plans whether it happens
exactly on that day I'm not able to
confirm at the moment what is your
understanding then of the joint approach
The Joint sunak hunt approach and all of
this I mean listening listening to the
Prime Minister yesterday on outside
number 10. you know I'll admit to being
a little confused I mean this is what he
said he was talking about giving us a
stronger NHS better schools safer
streets controllable borders protecting
our environment supporting our Armed
Forces I mean all of that surely
requires real-time spending increases
which is the one thing we're not going
to be getting well so I I think it's
really important
improving our schools yeah so we this
good government cannot just be about
spending lots more money
um we have to make sure that those
Public Services the Public Services in
which we all uh rely work effectively
efficiently and are very very delivery
focused but we can't just keep giving uh
uh you know above inflation uh spending
increases the maths the maths just
precludes that from happening so yes we
have to make sure that we keep a close
eye on public expenditure but also what
we've got to do is make sure we keep a
close eye on being very very delivery
focused now I'm not mutually exclusive
sure but when Jeremy Hunt talks about
making very very difficult decisions we
all know what that is called for and it
is cuts to public spending I mean we had
again from the Prime Minister yesterday
that he feels that there is a mandate
that flows from the 2019 manifest or an
election the one thing that anyone who
voted conservative back in 2019 did not
fought for was austerity well we've got
to remember that between the 2019
election and now we have had uh the
furlough scheme we have spent billions
hundreds of billions of pounds keeping
people's families together economically
keeping people in their jobs making sure
businesses don't go under so we have had
a massive massive massive increase in
public spending already we can't just
pretend that away those challenges those
challenges were then made worse by the
economic implications of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine so we but so we so
we can't just we can't just pretend that
expenditure has not happened we will
continue to support people people who we
know are struggling economically people
who we know are worried about the future
and we will of course support them but
we can't just pretend that that massive
amount of public expenditure hasn't
already happened
I I think I know the answer to this
question but it but it strikes me that
if you wanted to put forwards you know a
package of public spending cuts you know
one thing you need is a mandate given
that the Mandate was not provided by the
2019 manifest or why shouldn't there be
a general election now barring the fact
that the conservative party going by the
polling would be wiped out
because you always have to make Dynamic
decisions in government you can't set
out a a Manifesto and assume that
nothing uh significant is going to
happen over the phone
tax Rises so there'll be no public
spending so there will be so there was
no there was no there was no there was
no Global pandemic in the 2019 uh uh
Manifesto there was no invasion of
Ukraine in the 2019 manufacturing we
have got to respond to the world as we
find it not the one we wish it to be and
there have been two huge Global events
and they are affecting they are
affecting countries right across the
world I was on the phone yesterday to my
opposite numbers across the globe and we
are all facing these difficulties and we
all have to do it but especially soon I
admitted yesterday before he entered
number 10 mistakes were made and
mistakes were made by the conservative
government which exacerbated the
financial situation I do just want to
conclude on one thing though and you
mentioned it on pass on earlier that you
did support someone else that you
supported Boris Johnson I I have to ask
you you must have received some issue
agencies that he was going to stand when
he announced that he was not how did
that make you feel I mean he hung Nadeem
zahawi out to dry well we we could see
that the uh the support that he was
getting uh was uh around the hundred
mark that was enough for him to stand
his intention the conversations I had
with him his intention was to stand
annoyed well look I was I was
disappointed he didn't put himself
forward but ultimately it was becoming
clear even on uh the even on the you
know uh uh the the the Sunday Monday it
was becoming increasingly clear the
Parliamentary party
overwhelmingly wanted to see uh Rishi
sunak at the helm we absolutely respect
that Rishi is as I say an experienced
thoughtful and energetic politician I'm
very very happy to serve in his
government James gladly good to see you
we'll let you crack on on a busy day
thanks very much